it's safe to say that Star Wars is
likely the most popular film series of
all time not only have the official
chapters and growing number of offshoots
brought in billions of dollars they've
captivated hundreds of millions the
world over with classic stories of good
triumphing over evil but it takes a lot
of money time and effort to put a Star
Wars movie together which means once in
a while someone's going to blow it take
for example super blooper sci-fi films
naturally include dialogue with a lot of
technical words alien planets and races
unusual character names and assorted
other jargon actors have to work hard to
memorize all that stuff or at least be
able to read off of cue cards properly
but it's a fairly simple word that ended
up throwing off Mark Hamill while
filming a scene inside an x-wing
now it's give some distance before that
thing goes wrong that was good some
distance before that thing goes
supernova how do you pronounce
supernovas whipped inflection supernova
supernova man versus sword around one it
would seem that the proper handling of a
lightsaber is not really among Adam Liam
Neeson's well particular set of skills
anyway while portraying qui-gon jinn in
the Phantom Menace Neeson tried to
smoothly unsheath star wars trademark
weapon but says this take proves he
wasn't quite a real-life Jedi Master
let's see that again smooth tongue-tied
Tarkin bloopers can add a fascinating
dimension to extremely familiar movie
scenes take for example this well-known
moment from a new hope in which Princess
Leia begs and please of the
stone-hearted governor Tarkin and not to
blow up her adopted home planet actor
Peter Cushing reels around to chastise
her bus gets tongue-tied no rolled on as
peaceful we have no weapons you referred
another target a military target then
named well the struct name it now before
I get home man versus order round two at
some point in the last forty years
thousands of kids have staged and epic
imaginary lightsaber battle in that
bedroom in this blooper Hayden
Christensen looks just like a Star Wars
loving little boy up to the moment he
loses his balance and feels a force of
gravity okay duck stormtroopers blindly
serving the evil Darth Vader
stormtroopers are intimidating cutthroat
and unemotional agents of death and
destruction
what could possibly stop their march of
doom a hold too small to fit through
apparently as seen in this blooper from
a new hope
[Music]
droid down from the first Star Wars film
until his death in 2016 actor Kenny
Baker operated r2d2 from the inside it's
easy to forget that r2 is actually a
relatively clunky costume and not
actually an advanced droid that means
they can sip over all the controls can
suddenly go out as they did in these
bloopers on the Phantom Menace repulsion
um
you sure Oh Boober you sure all I know
your daddy captain let it go saying the
right words moving your body around the
right way and interacting with other
actors all at the same time and in the
correct order can be a lot to remember
and if an actor screws up just one of
those little things
it ruins our take in this scene from
Attack of the Clones Hayden Christensen
knew he was supposed to let go of
Natalie Portman's arm he just did it way
too early
are you going I know go on no you're not
let go of me obi-wan Kenobi after being
offered the role of obi-wan Kenobi but
before taking the parts Alec Guinness
called it fairytale rubbish he later
wrote in a letter during filming that he
didn't enjoy making the movie in part
due to what he called a rubbish dialogue
that resentment from the legendary
English actor is on display in this
blooper from the set of a new hope after
he's upstaged by one of two backers
hairy arms what a fun begin well haha
remember lines he cannot even the most
vocal the Phantom Menace attractor of
which there are many has to admit that a
highlight from the first long-awaited
Star Wars prequel was a return of Yoda
Frank Oz returned to provide the Jedi
Masters grammatically wonky voice and
even though ours wasn't physically on
camera at all he still seemed to get
nervous on set always true there are no
more no less
and now I forget
can I talk George thanks for watching
click the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel Plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you're not saying
[Music]